i did a movie
called megaforce
a lot of you haven't heard of it it was
a very interesting movie
when you say interesting as a producer
it means it didn't make any money
but
it was the movie was we were not
nominated by the academy that year they
were looking for something a little more
substantial
but the whole conceit behind the movie
the idea was a group of uh um rangers
who moved in these uh dune buggies at
very high speeds uh and and on the top
of the dune bodies with these massive
missiles that they launched in the
attack plan
well
the first step was to design these
missiles
hal
had a man he held with helen built the
land speed world speed record car that
smashed all records in bonneville and he
got his mechanic who designed the car to
design the rockets for megaforce
and then he called me one day said
bill's bringing with the rockets on the
lot and he wants to show it to us
i said okay we're on the goldwyn line
we called uh the head of security
and they sent a guard with bill
and his truck out to the back of the lot
when i got to the back of the lot i saw
this missile i almost fainted it was
about a thousand feet
long it looked like one of those
missiles you see on the news when the
russians are having the may day parades
you know this huge god damn
bill said like put these to your planet
and when i count to three you press the
button i was waiting to see what color
the smoke was coming out the back
so it went three two one i pressed the
button
the goddamn thing took off it went right
over the truck into the middle of the
gold one line i looked at database oh my
god we just got to kill people we must
have murdered people there's missiles
flying through the lot of cold one
we go running we go running down the lot
looking in this thing
as it came around the
corner is the new sound stage stage 10.
the number one was six feet tall
and the zero was six feet tall but in
the middle of the zero was a huge hole
this missile had gone into stage 10
where they were shooting
pennies from heaven with steve moore
i think that's it on top of everything
else we've murdered steve barton who was
bankable at that time incidentally so
you're not
we got it
luckily for us
they were not shooting at stage 10 that
day so we walked in and came in one way
and we couldn't find it where it went it
obviously was large in these huge
thick walls
we breathed sigh of relief and we went
back to the office i figured we really
dodged one
i was convinced of that for about an
hour
until i started hearing
helicopters coming over the line
and that were followed by fire engines
i looked out of my window
and stage 10 was a blaze
i told my secretary
do i have any scots do i have anything
to drink in its office at all
the stage burned down
luckily we had a hundred thousand dollar
insurance policy